So it turns out that this middle sheet of paper is going to make the box with
the biggest volume. But in order to really visualize that you have to put the
boxes together. So let's start out by doing that. Okay, so now we have three
boxes and I think it's time to make use of our M&amp;Ms now.
[NOISE][SOUND]
Okay, so I've filled each of these boxes with M&amp;Ms as best I can.
Unfortunately, I ran out over here, probably because I ate some of them. But I
think we can already tell, just by looking at the dimensions of this, little
skinny box. That its volume is definitely less than the other two boxes. It's
so flat, it can't possibly be the biggest. So now that we're left with two
choices. Now I could go through and count every single M&amp;M in this box and
every single M&amp;M in this box. But, I'm kind of lazy and that would take a
really long time. So, I will tell you that when I filled these M&amp;Ms it took me
several more handfuls of M&amp;Ms to fill this box than to fill this box. So that
means that its pretty good guess that this one has more volume. However as with
many things you see in this course I think we're going to need to do some math
to find a more rigorous way of analyzing the volume of any kind of box that we
could make out of a piece of paper.